[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here
and let's talk about 5g again we got
some updates so you might remember that
5g explain video we did a couple months
ago that really blew up we had a ton of
fun making it but naturally as you might
imagine there are a bunch of follow-up
questions
about roll out you see how can you cover
an entire city or an entire country for
that matter a whole planet in 5g
if a millimeter wave tower can only
cover half a city block well the answer
is there's going to be different ways to
build out 5g
some may describe it as a race to 5g i
would agree with dieter from the verge
it's not really a race because there
isn't really a finish line you just kind
of keep getting better over time but
also then there's this headline about
t-mobile getting a head start launching
5g across the us all at once but nobody
can use it until december 6th well
that's not completely true not nobody
so i was out in la a couple days ago
specifically to test t-mobile's new 600
megahertz 5g network
so here are my thoughts so i could have
gone to any number of places but the
weather is way nicer right now in la for
shooting outdoors so shout out to
t-mobile for allowing me to do some
exclusive testing for you guys and
thanks to oneplus for setting up this
video and providing the compatible 5g
phone and then shout out to john from
tld for helping me do a little testing
and to shoot this video okay so there
are going to be two phones that launch
on t-mobile to take advantage of this 5g
network oneplus 7t pro 5g mclaren
edition
and samsung galaxy note 10 plus 5g of
course i'm going to choose the slightly
faster of the two phones to stick with
the theme of this video plus it means
there's a good excuse to involve another
mclaren supercar so this
is testing 5g part 2.
[Music]
okay so i want you to check out this
clip cut out from a t-mobile 5g
hype video
it's working
it's working
nationwide 5g is live
okay so that was incredibly corny but
the point that they're trying to make is
they're basically lighting up 5g for 200
million people all at once on day one so
there are no like special 5g cities that
are popping up there are no city blocks
that are doing it and the reason they're
able to show this map and make that
claim
is low band 5g so you might remember
when i was talking about verizon 5g in
that first video we had to go all the
way to a specific 5g city and then find
a tower for that 5g area and then test
5g on like that one square block where
it was working and there have been
stories about nfl games where they're
trying to light up 5g in the stadium for
fans that day and they couldn't even
cover the whole stadium with 5g that
is millimeter wave and basically what we
found through our testing and i'll link
that video below the like button in case
you haven't seen it already but
basically what we found is those waves
do not travel very well and they don't
go through objects at all so you get
incredible speeds but not very far away
from the tower but as many of you
rightly pointed out
not all 5g is millimeter wave so the
t-mobile plan as they've explained it is
they want to start with low band 5g
which is anything under that one
gigahertz frequency
and then use their merger with sprint to
fill in more areas with mid band 5g and
then at the end fill in the gaps with
millimeter wave so they're starting at
the bottom and working their way up
instead of what verizon's done which is
start with millimeter wave so here we
are in sunny la casually driving around
a 2020 mclaren gt
with a mclaren edition oneplus 7t pro
5g and you just have 5g
everywhere so what do you get from low
band 5g well the main advantage is low
band can cover miles from a single cell
tower i know this because we drove
around miles from this cell tower to try
to test this and sure enough it stayed
locked to 5g the entire time we drove 5
10 15 minutes away still 5g behind
buildings under trees it bounced
effortlessly between a very small number
of towers as we drove so what's the
trade-off well low and mid-bands won't
get you those sexy thousand megabits per
second download speeds like you might
have if you're standing right next to a
millimeter wave tower but instead you'll
see somewhere between 20 to 50 percent
faster speeds than good 4g
and most of my tests were getting me
anywhere between 40 to 140 megabits per
second download speeds
and then somewhere from like 30 to 60
megabit up speeds which for me is right
in line with the best 4g speeds i've
ever gotten once or twice in my life but
now it's everywhere so
if i'm gonna get
5g 65 65 that would be
incredible
for me for lte so that's good
it's 25 26 27 28 up oh up okay 33 up
[Music]
36 that's really good like i mentioned
earlier i'm using the mclaren edition
oneplus 7t pro 5g and it looks exactly
like the mclaren edition oneplus 7t pro
that i have just with new 5g radios
inside all the same specs high refresh
rate snapdragon 855 plus 12 gigs of ram
and the 4085 milliamp hour battery
they're all still the same here so i
left the fancy alcantara case on the 5g
one just so i wouldn't get them mixed up
and i found the battery seemed to
diminish about the same rate as 4g but i
still got to take advantage of those
noticeably better speeds when doing
things like watching videos or
downloading a really large high quality
spotify playlist it's not the snap of a
finger that you might want it to be with
millimeter wave but it's still much
faster than 4g and anytime i start to
get comfortable with these speeds like
they weren't that great i just did a
side-by-side test with my phone which is
on att 4g and the difference was
definitely real so that is the main
advantage to starting a 5g rollout with
the lower and mid bands you don't get
the crazy
headline making speeds that might be
better for pr but on the other hand you
do get the advantage
more than half a block away from the
tower and so unlike having just
millimeter wave you will have everyone
who buys a 5g device affected pretty
much on day one instead of having to be
in a certain pocket of a certain town
yeah
faster
speaking of
faster the car we're driving
definitely faster than most cars matter
of fact i think mclaren knew exactly
what they were doing when they decided
to lend me a red and black car so
you know what while i'm not going to
review this car i figure i might as well
walk you through
some of the quirks and features that
i've noticed this
is the 2020 mclaren
gt so we've messed with other mclaren
cars before in the past this is their
newest most creature comfort full
version of a gt card stands for grand
tour which means there's a lot of things
that make it easier to drive on the
daily but there's still a lot of weird
interesting things about this car so
today i'll be taking a look at some of
its quirks and features so if you start
anywhere on a supercar you have to start
with where you get in and a lot of
prototype cars recently you sort of see
that there's no door handle and it's
perfectly smooth and that is the case
with the gt but there is a way to get in
you can see on the back of the door
there's a little cutout and that's
actually the door handle so to get in
you push in and it'll roll the frameless
window down a bit and unlock it and
that's how you can swing the door open
and get inside your mclaren and then
you'll also notice for a daily
driver-focused car with nice leather
seats and tons of extra space there's
still not a ton of interior space in
fact there is no glovebox in this car so
as a passenger your only options for
storage are this small smartphone size
net in the footwell near your feet
or these little cubbies on the inside of
each door that fold down so you can fit
anything in them that's i guess a water
bottle size or less but speaking of
storage space one place you will find a
lot more of it is in the front trunk of
the mclaren gt and there are three ways
to open the front trunk of this car you
can press the front trunk button on the
key or on the left side of the steering
wheel you can find a button with the
same image press that and it'll open the
front trunk from the inside of the car
or if you're outside the car you can get
out and there's actually another
identical button on the door only
visible when the door is open so there's
no way you forget you have a front trunk
and the front itself as you can see when
it's open is actually quite big bigger
in fact than the tesla model s and i fit
a suitcase full of video gear in there
just fine uh not that i use video gear
um you could even fit more if you wanted
to
this car also has uh something extremely
rare for a supercar with a 200 plus mile
an hour top speed and that's a power
rear lift gate and a ton of extra trunk
storage where you could theoretically
store an entire bag of 18 golf clubs no
kidding but my favorite gizmo in the
mclaren gt has to be
the sunroof the electrochromatic
adjustment so right below the glass roof
here there are some buttons basically a
touch screen that lets you actively
adjust the level of tint
on the sunroof so if the sun is really
beating down during the peak of the day
you can add tint or if you want to see
more you can turn it down super quick
and super impressive so now of course
i should drive it
sorry i got off track there uh this
isn't autofocus but i'll leave the real
doug demiro video on the mclaren gt that
he already did below check that out but
anyway there you have it
that is low and mid band
5g in a nutshell so really it turns out
one of the most interesting parts about
5g is the rollout and you know there's
no right or wrong answer but which
rollout strategy is better the verizon
way right now which is doing millimeter
wave in these hyper local tiny areas and
getting those sexy headline making
speeds and then doing mid band later or
the t-mobile way which is flipping the
switch on low and mid band first and
covering as many people as possible
getting everyone those bumps and speeds
and seeing the nice advantage but not
making the headlines and filling in the
gaps with millimeter wave later let me
know what you think i'm definitely
curious also mclaren and oneplus are
having a contest that i'll link the
details to below where you can win the
5g phone and a sort of mclaren driving
experience kind of similar to what i
just had which was a lot of fun so if
you want to check that out that's below
as well either way
thank you for watching
and i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace